all right Doug yeah Doug away from
originally where'd you grow up I am from
El Paso Texas I've been born there
raised mostly in Albuquerque New Mexico
and Las Cruces New Mexico I split time
between my mother and my dad's parents
back and forth as a kid
but then by high school I was in
Albuquerque full time
tell me about your family your uh your
parents oh man I'm a mama's boy 100
um it was my mom and my dad until I was
two and then my dad took off
uh my mother was just you know she just
loves with her whole heart and she had
another daughter
about when I was six she had a daughter
my sister Amanda
and um we were it was just the three of
us for a good while and then my mom my
mom was married five times when I was
younger different guys coming in and out
but uh you know it was just always the
three of us even still to this day it's
the three of us we're real close and
your dad was kind of out of the picture
yeah he was out of the picture he
checked this out he moved away like left
my mom to live in a ditch like left my
mom to be homeless because it was seemed
better to him apparently and then he
joined the army when I was a toddler and
got out when I was eight and I spent
about
for about a year with him before that
just it just wasn't it just wasn't
happening you know and he really didn't
have much of interest in it and so then
I came back to my mom and that's where I
was for most of that time and your
childhood was good with Mom yeah I mean
you know as good as it is for a single
mother and and two kids you know making
forty thousand dollars a year yeah it
was it was great she always provided
everything she could
um but
yeah it wasn't without its struggles for
sure but I mean whose childhood is whose
childhood is yeah
and uh how far is you in school
school was pretty boring for me I I
found that I I just
you know what was easy I did right away
and what wasn't easy I just didn't do
and um I was I was just I was a real
strong-willed kid stubborn's probably a
better word my mother would use much
more
harsh words than that but uh I was a
stubborn kid and didn't really have time
for anybody to tell me anything and a
lot of times I found that people didn't
tell me anything you know like in high
school I just you weren't supposed to
leave campus but I would just drive by
the security guard wave in and they'd
wave back I never understood why to be
honest but nobody really ever
stopped me from being the [__] that
I was when I was younger and so it just
kind of continued stubborn stubborn
stubborn did you do you have goals of
doing things your dreams doing things in
your life everything for me was
Athletics and sports I love sports
um I really wanted to be a professional
athlete more than anything I remember
you know I think my mom says when I was
a kid people used to be like hey how are
you and I'll be like hi I'm Michael
Jordan
you know I just love basketball and I
just love competing and playing sports
and that's all I really that's where my
heart has been
um so I did have dreams of being a
professional athlete want to go to
college playing basketball
um didn't really work out I actually
turned out more athletically inclined to
play football and less mentally inclined
to play football
I love basketball and didn't really find
a home in football so it lasted a year
so
that was about it
um
I I remember I really wanted to be a
writer
and that never happened but uh
yeah so after after high school I just
joined the army right away
um I actually had to take a special test
that would allow me to join the Army
before I was 18. I call it the Amos test
and I passed that test and so then they
let me in the Army right away but I only
lasted like a year and a half before I
got thrown out
I made it through all my training got to
my first Duty station and then
and then discovered that you know
cocaine was available there too so I
failed a drug test pretty quick I mean
all in all I was in the Army less than
two years so you're using cocaine yeah
yeah when did I start
oh probably high school late high school
I just you know I figured out what it
was because you know I had a job most of
high school I worked at like an Arby's
or a restaurant I had a couple different
jobs but because I had jobs you always
meet older people and older people have
drugs so I found drugs pretty young
um and found that I liked them
but uh
so I yeah but but in the Army I I I was
using it for a little bit because I
found it I was in Italy that was my
first Duty station was in Italy and they
you know they just don't supervise all
that much and like I said
I never really found a reason to stop
being a stubborn ass that I was
how old are you now I'm 35 35.
and as you got out of the army yeah and
would you do then I got to the Army and
commenced to continue doing drugs
basically and and just I mean a nice way
to put it I was trying to find my way a
bad way to put it I was just [__]
around and doing whatever the hell I
wanted
um but yeah so I continued doing drugs
felony methamphetamine pretty hard
pretty fast out of the army I remember
my girlfriend's dad at the time gave me
a job he was a property manager so he
gave me a job as like a maintenance guy
at these apartments and then I I lost
that job within like two or three weeks
because I was either getting I think I
was getting high on the job like doing
coke on the job or whatever but so that
continued and then intensified into
methamphetamine
pretty quick by the time I was like 22
23.
and you know then I bounced around
getting in trouble got arrested a couple
times landed myself on probation for a
good amount of time in Albuquerque and
uh
and that's really where I discovered
bodybuilding or or started putting it
into practice anyway and by the grace of
God here I am so bodybuilding kind of it
sounds like it almost saved your life a
little bit oh absolutely yeah it
absolutely Saved My Life um I like to
say that
as I've been on this journey every step
of the way it has been it has been
reinforced to me that it's what I'm
supposed to do you know I mean I think
that a lot of times people
not very many people get to discover
that the thing they love
more than anything can also be the thing
that provides them with a living and you
know is the thing they're supposed to do
for life and I count myself very lucky
very fortunate to be able to to say that
they're like there's
you know that it's every step of the way
through bodybuilding it's you know I
feel like God has been like yeah this is
where you're supposed to be man this is
what you're supposed to be doing good
job and so I mean like a lot of ways
that's that's the the main source of
motivation for me to keep going when
times get tough so your motivation to to
I mean you're you're big as a house your
shoulders are like bowling bowling balls
what what's the motivation behind it
were you picked on as a kid
no I really wasn't picked on as a kid
like I said
people I was kind of an outsider for
sure like uh but I was I was The
Outsider that that that people I mean I
was respected especially because I
played Sports and and stuff nobody
messed with me but nobody you know
nobody messed with me negatively but
then not very many people mess with me
positively like I wasn't one of the
popular kids that's for sure
um I think my motivation for for
training is has changed so many times
over the course of this journey it
started as just a hunger for it was an
outlet uh an outlet for all this energy
I had to just go in there and train
and noticed that I had control over
something in my life like you know I
have control over this nobody else
there's really no outside influence if I
show up I do the work I eat the food you
know this is what's gonna happen and
that was a big motivation for me and and
it helped me to discipline myself
you know as I learned to live without
the drugs because you know I feel like
if you start if you start doing drugs
you're like 17 you don't really learn
how to live you know it's like when
you're an early Bloomer you actually
miss all the lessons and you're
technically a late bloomer anyway you
just fake into an early bloom or
whatever but
so that was my first that was really my
first main motivation was I just
remember loving that I had this to do
every day and it made me feel this way
and I could see the changes in my body
like it was my cousin and I were the
first ones to start going to the gym
together right when I got out of the
army before
I had really gotten into the trouble and
so you know we were going to the gym and
we'd be training and guys were asking
have you ever thought about bodybuilding
and I was like oh no man I'm too tall to
be a bodybuilder there's no way like you
guys are also short and small and you
know that's why they look so big and the
guy was like one guy I just remember
just told me was like
well you're wrong
so when you're when you realize you're
wrong and you want to go through with
this because you will come find me and
sure enough like that's what it was like
you know over a couple of months I just
noticed that you know my cousin
you know his body changed but not like
mine you know it was like it was like
he's like this and I just went boom you
know my back just that was naturally
yeah yeah my body just blew up I've seen
some people do it naturally where they
just get big as a house yeah it's like
that's one of the first ways I knew that
oh this is what I'm supposed to do
because I played Sports in high school
and stuff and I was I was a good athlete
but I wasn't a star player I wasn't a
starter on the basketball team or or
like uh you know on football I just sat
on the bench but I was always the
strongest like always in the weight room
they were like who what is Doug doing
over there
and so that kind of performance really I
mean like I said I always wanted to be a
professional at something and and
bodybuilding took that from
where all the other sports dropped off
you know because I wasn't going to be a
college basketball player that's for
sure and then I screwed up everything in
the Army so there was that you have a
longer career doing this absolutely I
mean
you know yeah I say that I I joked my
uncle told me he's like well they they
taught you how to defend your family and
taught you everything you need to know
about how to be a tough hard-nosed dude
and then you got out without you know
having to go to war it seemed like a
pretty good deal
um
you know there's a lot of guilt and
shame that I carried along with that for
a long time but all in all I think yeah
it was a pretty good deal have you
competed
yet bodybuilder not yet I didn't compete
my first show was in 2012. so I trained
for a good few years and I ran into a
pro bodybuilder in New Mexico his name
is JoJo he's retired now but he's still
like the main guy in Albuquerque as a
you know trainer or coach and I ran into
him and he he helped me get ready for my
first show
um it was the midst of New Mexico
and I
you know as a first show I I definitely
prepared as well as I could and there
was only one super heavyweight me I was
you know because super heavy weights 225
pounds and so I've been heavier than
that since I can remember really but you
know and honestly there I probably could
have been less than the 225 pounds but
it was my first show
um didn't do that but overall I won
because I was the only guy there that
was cool and it was a great experience
um but that was my first competition and
then I went to Texas and did this show
called The Lone Star Classic the same
year
um
that was fun but then I took a few years
off before going back to the midst of
New Mexico in 2014.
and and to achieve a body like yours a
person can't really do that naturally oh
no I don't believe so no I mean I would
I would hope not like mine I always joke
if people have to ask if you're on
steroids and you're really doing it
wrong
you know if they have to wonder as far
as bodybuilding is concerned but um
drugs started pretty young with me too I
didn't compete for my first show my
first two shows I didn't use anything
um but after that I did and it wasn't
for lack of wanting to it's just because
I nobody had offered them to me yet you
know
um being from Albuquerque surely is
surely not the same as being in La
um where it's everywhere you know but uh
in Albuquerque nobody had offered it to
me yet I hadn't met the right people but
I still trained and tried all the pro
hormones as you buy a GNC and stuff like
that
um but then once I found him yeah
you know it's part of the game
um
it's definitely not something we talk
about much and I think that's good I
mean I look at it just like another kind
of medication you know we you know it's
it's my own personal business
yeah yeah it's I don't think it's an
addictive destructive drug like uh some
of the other crazy drugs you you were
you were trying before yeah I mean it's
definitely not as destructive
um
health-wise or lifestyle wise for sure I
will I would say that they're somewhat
addictive though
um in certain circumstances
psychologically yeah psychologically I
mean we you know for one you feel so
much more powerful
um
when you're training with them it's just
it's a different experience I'm not
going to say that you know you can't
feel as good training naturally because
I have and I do frequently sometimes
when I'm off cycle but uh it's
definitely not the same and the other
reason is you know as as guys get older
the steroids really cover up a lot of
those aches and pains that you basically
feel all the time if you've been
training your whole life so when you
come off it hurts you know hurts the
knees you got to take more Ibuprofen you
got to take Toradol and cortisone
sometimes you know a lot of a lot of
stuff guys struggle with that and so I
can see why you know it's kind of scary
sometimes come off because it's going to
hurt I see you at the gym every day
right yep you're every day of the year
every day yeah every day I'll take a
break sometimes but only like if I'm on
vacation or something like that
um it's actually really hard to get me
to agree to take a day off you know I'll
find a way it is a psychological benefit
to doing this too well absolutely you
know you must renew your mind everything
that's where I go I'm not a bodybuilder
I'm just I just find it helps me
mentally oh absolutely
um I I feel like bodybuilding is the
the result of a process that I would do
anyway you know I mean I love I love the
bodybuilding lifestyle and I love the
way you know I love the way my body
looks don't get me wrong but it's
definitely not so much a part of my ego
as it was four years ago
and I I mean I'm happy for that it's
much more mentally easy and and and I
think it puts a much more spot positive
spin on it younger bodybuilders tend to
be so negative all the time
about themselves about everybody who you
know I think it's part of growing yeah
can you buy a dress shirt or buy a suit
I just got married actually last year
and I was able to find a suit on the
rack
um it's a 50 regular
but it had to be tailored and then the
shirt I I did actually have it made
custom it's nicer to have them made
custom because then of course it fits
better like have you ever seen Dave
Batista or Dwayne Johnson in a suit like
they're tailored suits and they look
much better than if you look at like the
if you go to the Olympia press
conference sometimes the guys will wear
suits and they're not tailored and they
just look like big sacks of really nice
fabric
so what what is the goal to become
stronger or to be more powerful in
appearance or
um as you know
obviously the goal competitively if you
know as I continue to compete in
bodybuilding is to get to the Mr Olympia
and in that in that regard it's just all
about Aesthetics you know it's about
symmetry size definition and
conditioning
um that's the standard bodybuilding
bodybuilding criteria so as far as
competitively yeah that's what I'm after
but then as far as my life I want to be
the strongest biggest and most
mobile example that I can find in my own
human potential I look at bodybuilding
now much more as a expression of human
potential and an expression of human
capability
to the to its furthest extent and that
helps me as a trainer as well to just
help other people explore their
optimal level of physical fitness
because not everybody wants to be at the
Paramount of their physical fitness
potential you know I do because it's
what I love you know and I understand
that a lot of people love other things
but they also would like to be in shape
um so there's two different you know
there's two goals for me and they
intertwine a lot as I grow in the
maximum human capability side the the
competitive side kind of dwindles
because that's somebody else's opinion
of what you're doing as opposed to your
opinion of what you're doing but they're
still both in there very much so but a
lot of this is aesthetic oh yeah yeah
aesthetic for sure because like you
probably could throw a ball or run
faster when you were in high school or
when you were younger definitely run
faster not when you were how much what
do you weigh now like right about 300
pounds 300 yeah yeah so when you you're
running on 300 pounds you're throwing a
ball with that much mass on your arms
and shoulders yeah no I can throw a
football like I love to play catch and I
love all those little Boyhood games but
yeah like I can throw a football maybe
15 times before my elbow starts hurting
and and I have a t-shirt that literally
says if I'm running you should be too
because that's about the only reason
that I would be it's pretty funny
what advice would you give to somebody
who's considering taking a path like
this yeah man I mean I would say that
I would say that it's it's an awesome
path to take and I would I would
encourage them to explore it extensively
and to come in with an open mind and to
find real true
um mentors you know be be not an online
guy not somebody that you know go to the
gym and find a guy that's there every
day and become friends with them and
just just experience it more so than
expect anything from it
um
I I honestly believe that like if you're
meant to be a bodybuilder you'll pick up
a dumbbell and you'll feel it you know
you'll get a pump and you'll be like
yeah I'm supposed you know you'll feel
it and you'll go with it so that's why I
say just go in and explore it explore
your body's capabilities explore your
level of fitness and and notice how you
can definitely make it better for
yourself it's one of the few places in
the world that
few play parts of our life I feel like
where you have
total control just what what you can do
I think control is a big part big factor
in this whole bodybuilding thing I think
so too for women as well yeah I
definitely think so I think I think I
think that uh
not not women that are necessarily
becoming big like you are but which
which there are but the women that are
just lean and ripped and all that yeah I
think it's a way for them to you know to
to feel strong in the rest of their life
and to to feel like they I mean one
thing that I think like you said you
know when you come to the gym every day
it's it's for your mental aspect like
you know having that that level of
discipline to make sure that happens
every day that carries over into
everything else in life it's not just
like that's the only thing that you're
disciplined in and I think simply the
practice of discipline as a whole is is
important to to your quality of life
like there's that guy that says
discipline equals freedom
you know what what kind of reactions do
you get from people oh man
when you're outside the gym so many you
know like walking down Venice Beach you
can always get somebody's gonna come up
and ask you to arm wrestle him
somebody's gonna come up and ask you how
much you're going to bench you know how
much can you bench a lot of people just
oh my God you know you get a lot of
reactions you really do
um and they vary so much it's great to
see people you know like motivated even
though sometimes kind of uncomfortable
when you're like you know I've literally
had people come to me and be like man
you make me feel like [__] and I'm like
that's not what I'm supposed to make you
feel you're supposed to feel like you
see possibility for where you could be
you know but of course some people take
it negative some people like man you
just inspire me I'm going to the gym and
I'm like awesome that's good you know
um
a lot of people
I think especially when you don't know
me and you see me a lot of people think
I'm pretty mean and so they'll just kind
of gawk at me without coming up to say
something but usually as soon as
somebody comes to talk to me we have a
good conversation and it's great
I find it interesting that like you you
and I go to the gym at 4 45 in the
morning every day every day and uh there
are
a whole slew of people that are doing
the same exact thing they're they're
there every day of the year
and I suspect of that a big portion of
them had some kind of alcohol drug
problem some kind of problem that they
were dealing with earlier in their lives
and the gym has replaced that yeah yeah
I see that a lot I mean a lot of the
guys that I mean because I'm there
at 4 45 with you for that group but then
I stay all morning you know I leave
about two o'clock in the afternoon
because you're you're training people
because I'm training people there and
you'd be very surprised the amount of
Alcoholics Anonymous you know people
that are there a lot and other substance
abusers I mean myself included I I feel
like I mean there's a scientific reason
for that I think that dopamine that we
get from drugs
we also get from training you know that
and that's a chemical in our brain that
that chemicals released when we're
training when we're running when we're
doing any sort of exercise
just the same as it is when you're doing
a line of blow right so I think in a lot
of ways we become addicted to that but
in the psychological benefits of this I
think are great too yeah they they calm
that energy inside of you I think it's
it for me you know it's like we have so
much a lot of guys have so much tension
and energy inside of us and that kind of
allows us to work through it and and
calm calm ourselves a little bit more
yeah I think a lot of people
have figured this out and are just
really you know like even in my life
when I've had really rough patches
exercise working out has has really
helped keep stabilize me it stabilizes I
mean it's it it literally brought me
from the depths of a place I can't
imagine that I was to where I am now
which is a blessing beyond belief you
know what was your what was your darkest
point
I remember being in jail
um
looking out the little window
and I was reading a letter my mom would
read me a letter so I've been there
I've been there like a week a week and a
half so this is like the first letter my
mom wrote to me since I had been
arrested and I was reading it and said
it said it
I mean some other stuff but basically I
remember reading don't call me I won't
answer the phone
if you want to talk to me I'm here for
you you can write me but you need to
figure yourself out and get yourself on
the right track when you're cleaned up
and sober you can come and talk to me
again that was for my mother and and you
know like I said earlier my mother and I
she's been I mean she's always been my
rock but we went through a really rough
patch when I was being the most stubborn
I have been but that was probably my
darkest moment because I remember
looking outside that little jail window
and and I mean keep in mind you know I'm
I'm 20 22 ish still young so young and
I'm looking out here and there's all
these real grown men that are very scary
looking
and I'm I just I it was the first moment
I realized dude you're all alone here
like if you're gonna have a lawyer
you're gonna get it if you're gonna get
out of this you're gonna do it nobody's
out on there you know like my mom's not
bailing me out my mom's not calling a
lawyer she's not doing any of that
um
and so that was probably that was
probably my darkest point because I just
really remember feeling so
lost like holy like it was the first
time I really realized dude what are you
doing with your life you know what is
happening to you
it's crazy if you had your life to live
all over again would you have done
things differently early on especially
it's hard to say I mean I feel like
that's how you learn that's how you
learn and that's how you become who you
are you know and so as I look at myself
now
and I I realized that a lot of times I
meet people that don't have the same
level of compassion or empathy or
understanding or patience that I do and
I I cherish those things in myself and I
don't feel like I would have them if I
hadn't experienced some of the things
I've experienced been some of the places
I've been
and also you know like I'm not gonna I
obviously I definitely did not do it on
my own but I mean I crawled out of that
pit you know I was on probation for six
years in Albuquerque while working
full-time and bodybuilding before 2014
came and it was like okay now you can be
off probation and go go go and I left
and came to LA right away
you know so I feel like I really
I willed it to happen and by the grace
of God with his support I I put myself
here and I mean I'm just now
getting you know we're still working on
things we're still getting on the road
but
it was not having your dad a big part of
your life a factor in in any of this I'm
sure it was I hate to blame it on that
like I hate to say like oh yeah because
my dad wasn't here I [__] up here and
I did this and I did that because
because then you just I
you know maybe maybe not but I would I
feel like if you do that you're
absolving yourself of some sort of
responsibility and it's like
I never wanted to do that I never wanted
to admit that weakness in myself that
something like that would would cause me
to have
you know these issues that I can't
overcome so I don't like to blame it on
that but yeah man I mean it baffles me
that I might have had
you know overall
two years tops total with my father as a
kid but still even at 35 years old I
think about him every day
you know and and that just that just
kind of tells you the the seriousness of
that inherent bond between a father and
a son that
that you know a lot of people say that's
where we establish our identity as boys
um so maybe it did have a huge effect
maybe it's a subconscious thing maybe
I'm still in the process of re-parenting
myself I don't know yeah yeah but but
you've done a great job of that I've
done everything I can you know there's a
lot of things I wish
one thing that I think was really rough
with me was when I was younger I just I
didn't learn how bad being dishonest
with people was
you know as a young as a young man I
like it's like you know you tell a lie
and and you know I didn't realize until
I was like 20 25 maybe then it's like
when you tell someone a lie that changes
their opinion of you immensely like it's
not just like oh man he told me
something that wasn't true it's like
damn that dude [__] that guy you know
I didn't honestly as a kid nobody
explained that to me
and a lot of times I'd be like well if I
just say this they'll think this and
that'll be fine
and that was a lot of
I don't know a lot of
a lot of crazy [__] when I was a kid
that I feel like
bodybuilding really
it was
through my young adult life and
everything that was where I put all of
my negative energy so I didn't have to
think about it so much and that's why I
was able to build you know
whatever I built here the life that I
have now
um just by compartmentalizing it into
training you know
and stuff like that and just
I don't know maybe ignoring it more than
I should have maybe not processing it as
much but we got where we are do you have
days where you just don't feel it you're
just tired and run down and oh yeah
sometimes and what do you do well I try
to avoid those days by maintaining my
schedule and having a rest day before
that happens you know that's the real
goal so sleep's a big part of her we all
sleeps huge I mean I had to once as I
gained as I got this size on me I had to
go and get a CPAP because I couldn't
sleep without choking
and so now I have a CPAP and sleep is
great it's a CPAP the CPAP is a
breathing device you put on while you
sleep and it forces air down your throat
because as we get bigger it happens to
obese guys too but as as we get bigger
and we lay on our back the the weight of
our chest muscles push into our
diaphragm and so then it closes off and
we stop breathing
um so you have to have a CPAP as a
device that pushes air in and pulls air
out while you're sleeping because while
we're awake our brain takes care of it
it's in your mouth no it's like a mask
like an oxygen mask you sleep with it
yeah and you sleep with it it took me a
long time to figure that out that was a
that's an adventure the CPAP but I mean
otherwise nobody can sleep in the same
room with you you know because you just
you're so loud and you wake up all the
time and it's actually the leading cause
of atrial fibrillation so if you if you
have sleep apnea make sure you go get a
CPAP because it'll kill your heart what
are some of the other problems that you
have with a carrying around a body like
this oh close you mentioned it closes
tough
um sitting in cars is not easy with legs
like this you know I can only sit in the
car for like an hour before things start
hurting flying sucks
um eating I mean let's just talk about
the amount of food I eat going out to
dinner is ridiculous
um traveling in general you know I have
a bag of food with me everywhere how
many calories do you eat a day almost 8
000 most of the time now a thousand
calories a day 8 000 calories a day it's
I tell people my job is this it's it's
eating first training other people
second and working out is my third job
like that's how it goes I literally my
entire day is structured around my food
like that's why I asked you to come in
early because look if then I don't have
to bring food I can go home and eat at
12 and I'm on schedule you know
um the health the health problems I I
have really worked hard to not have many
of those
um I think all of us would say that but
I really have been pretty proactive
especially once I turned 30.
um you know I do my blood work like
every three months I actually went to a
doctor and said my my words to my doctor
was it's time for me to legitimize my
bodybuilding life and and stop taking
steroids out of the back of someone's
car you know like and so I was like
let's legitimize this and do this the
way
the real pros at the top level do it
um and that has really helped me a lot I
think but uh
but so I haven't the the sleep apnea is
really the only thing as long as you
keep your blood pressure in check you
keep your liver enzymes in check and you
keep your kidneys in check
you know you're going to be okay for the
most part blood pressure is a big one do
you drink or smoke pot I smoke a lot of
pot I smoke pot like cigarettes
um I'm not going to really say that's
for bodybuilding that's more for calming
my mind than well I live in L.A it's
kind of just the way it goes but I don't
drink very often I like a glass of wine
with a good steak like anybody else but
uh definitely
definitely not a partier you know like I
we went on a cruise last year that was
the one time we got drunk but it's very
rare very rare
Doug what would you say is the most
important lesson you've learned in all
of this the beauty is the journey
that's my favorite that's the most
important lesson I learned I remember
you strive so hard for a destination
that you forget all the lessons you're
learning and and I like to say that
every time you prepare for a show
there's a less you know because the
preparation is like 16 weeks long worth
of scheduled structured exercise and
cardio and through that time you know
there's a lot of perseverance and so we
learn a lot about ourselves and a lot
about life and and every prep for me has
had its own lesson and the prep in which
I turn pro the lesson was that
was that the beauty is not in the final
destination that's actually the saddest
part of the journey is the end
the beauty is every step along the way
yeah even if you're wildly successful in
that endeavor absolutely five years
later you look back at it and you'll
long for the the building for the
building it yeah uh I think yeah that
was that was one of the biggest things
that I came to understand was that this
is what we love because as a younger
bodybuilder you're so attached to
everybody else you're so attached to
what they say what they think the judges
the media the sponsors you know that's
what it's all about and so you're posing
and you're hoping you're going to get
these responses and you're hoping
they're going to like you
and you forget that like that's so
fleeting and so meaningless compared to
the process of getting there and the the
process of Mastery of anything but but
bodybuilding is you know it's it almost
changed from a sport to a martial art
for me and as a martial art it's much
more fulfilling
excellent Doug thank you so much for
sharing your story man thank you thanks
for having me that was beautiful
tomorrow morning yep thanks man